in the lecture yesterday I tried to
offer a common denominator for the
various domain of scholarship as Gary
just said by building upon the notion of
agency I claim that Scholars whatever
the many differences in the skill of a
master are those who try to make sure
that when an agent is introduced into
the world it position or its competence
or per sorry its substance its Essence
the word doesn't matter is always
connected with it action of the
performances actualities or attribute if
you want such a connection certain that
it's always possible to move from the
trial for which the properties have been
slowly assembled to the essence of the
phenomenon or conversely from its
Essence back to the situated mundane
material setup out of which it has
emerged I argue that it's this double
connection that ensures the
accountability of a discipline and in
addition I claim maybe too polemically
that such a way of being accountable has
not much to do with that which is the
enemy of scholarship as well of basic
research evaluation which means fitting
in form so that you may be made
redundant faster and with less
protestation the tools I offered
yesterday come from iotics broadly
conceive but is from an attention to the
textuality of account provided by the
many discipline of natural philosophy of
scholarship even though it's slightly
irritating for many scientists to be
reminded of such an elementary fact they
all do right account we all do of what
has happened in the valious setup they
have built with great care and sometimes
at Great expense this is true no matter
if we deal with the mathematical
formalism of ant colonies Expeditions on
the canopies of the Amazon forest
visualization of neuron firing in the OC
campus survey research on gender
discrimination or etimology of the word
pragat in Aristotle philosophy as well
as the immensely long history of air
bubbles trapped in Antarctic Ice cores
they all have in the end to write a
report it is this common concentration
of production assemblage collation gloss
and summary of textual document that
allows all of us as member of what I
still want to call a university inside
our value scriptoria or maybe we should
invent the word screen dya to say that
we are the Son and Daughters of exegesis
so many scribes interpreting the trace
left on disjointed documents for the
careful application of our share
interpreted itive skill I found this
yesterday this very Charming example by
commentary by a physicist called Kim
benabed about a new discovery on
gravitational waves which has been
obtained for an instrument called BP 2
in Antarctica and he said he is very
excited by the discovery we are going to
look at every comma of their paper
shifting attention from the trace of the
Big Bang to the comma in the paper is
adding two exis IAL skill one on top of
another I think conversation between
discipline will be much clarified if we
instead of using data we were using the
word subl that is what is obtained not
what is
given there are at least two reason why
I think it's important to stitch back
together the har quote of the old
University and to bring slightly closer
together the friends of interpretable
object whichever part of the campus they
come from
the first reason proper to semiotic is
that it allows us to focus attention as
I said yesterday not simply on the
literary or narrative aspect of a
scientific literature which is useful in
itself but on what I have proposed to
call the metamorphic Zone where humans
and non-humans keep exchanging their
property that is their
figuration a non-anthropomorphic
character is a character all the same it
has agency it moves it under goes trial
it elicit reaction it becomes
describable this however does not mean
that we are projecting anthropomorphic
features on what should remain an object
it simply means that the shape that is
the morphism of a human character is
just as open to inquiry to shape
changing as that of a
non-human put more bluntly it means that
the older philosophical tools of object
and subject are wholly inadequate to
follow the description the many account
that are pouring out of our scriptoria
be their laboratory office space Studio
Etc here something else is at work has
always been at work something that does
modify the shapes of what whichever
ingredient you throw inside much like a
fiercely boiling sorcerer
cauldron the second reason to try to
repair Harlan's shredded mantle is what
I call a new political or more
adequately a new diplomatic situation as
I showed at the end of a lecture
yesterday citing whad we cannot pick and
choose because the older contract that
had distributed the domain of
scholarship to Natural scientist the
objective natural world to the rest of
the discipline the more subjective
aspects of human life this contrast has
been destroyed by the very advance of
human intervention in the elementary
features of our terrestrial
existence what had learned what had
earlier been a mere epistemological
question how is the human mind able to
know the word objectively has become a
totally practical question how can we
describe life on Earth in which human
traces are so
ubiquitous that natural and artificial
have become impossible to set
apart the convenient although
controversial term to register this new
historical situation is itself a
fascinating hybrid of geology and
politics namely the word anthropocene
this is an image of the anthropocene and
the funny thing is that the anthropocene
is so small that it's actually no bigger
that if they try to put there which is a
small thing there after the osen very
very very small indeed and in case you
don't know at all about the anthropos
scene after all we are in the country of
climat skeptic so I have to be careful
here
this is the great acceleration one of
the proponents Stefan and kuden are the
proponent of the anthropos argument this
is a three different dimension which are
of course very rough but it's just an
indication of the footprint of humans
1900 the small par piped there
1950 about my birth time when I was born
and this is where we are now the the
size of a footprint as you see is pretty
big and when we say anthropos scene we
should REM be reminded that it's of
course rather the Euros scene because
it's of course not every country on
earth is has the same responsibility in
this situation and just this little
thing to give you an idea of my feeling
this is I took when I took the plane
coming here uh in earlier time I would
have seen the ice and then I would have
seen the reactors of a be boing with
great pleasure but has separated things
but now when you look at the ice and
at the Boeing itself you feel that they
are related so that the distinction
between the foreground and background is
actually gone it's as if you were in a
sort of mous trip and that's what the
osine tries to capture you try you start
with the ice and you end up with the
boing and vice versa it's very difficult
now to see the eyes just as a spectacle
in the new old new old id or old new ID
of a landscape there's no landscape
anymore we are in it and the scientists
know that this is the originality of the
uh
situation so that's the name anthropos
is the name of the sorcerer Quron at the
time of the anthropos now that history
has become geostory the very shape of
humans and non-human have hold to be
remixed hence the necessity of entirely
restitching the geopolitic maps of the
many discipline in charge of studying
such a mixture it's no longer in the
power of one description to eliminate
alternative description without trial
they may be in Conflict but they cannot
be annihilated they have to compose
maybe to
compromise before we head first in the
difficult topic of today let us stroke
the flank of a cauldron to check how hot
it is a recently written upad in the New
York time if you see something say
something will help me show where the
prime reside Michael E man is the author
of the book the title of which is a
perfect symptom of a period I'm pointing
at the hocky stic and the climate Wars
dispatches from the front lines
apparently news coming from science have
become comparable now to those From The
Trenches of gual canal or ver which is
the new situation if scientists choose
not to engage in the public debate we
leave a vacuum that will be filled by
those whose agenda is one of short-term
self-interest he said there's a great
cost to society if scientists fail to
participate in the larger
conversation if we do not do all we can
to ensure that the policy debate is in
form by an honest assessment of risk in
fact it would be an abrogation of our
responsibility to society if we remain
quite in the face of such a grave threat
but Sly he says a radical position our
Department of Homeland Security has
heard citizen to report anything
dangerous they witness if you see
something say something we scientists
are citizen too and in climate change we
see a clear and present
danger what is especially interesting in
this upad and also very moving is that
Michael man is simultaneously trying to
extricate himself from an older
settlement there should be a firewall to
keep science and politics apart while
having the utmost difficulty in article
ating an
alternative we risk playing the role of
the activist that our enemies the
deniers of climate mutation denounce but
if we fail to get into The Fray We Run
The symmetric risk of abandoning our
duties as scientists which is to warn
people of the danger surrounding them
that we have
detected what is for me very revealing
in this example and you can find
hundreds of them is that to his surprise
Michael man is dealing with types of
State that are crossing over the
distinction between facts and values
it's about facts that are there that are
dangerous that are denied by enemies and
that should be told to the public no
wonder that in the title of this book he
has to resort to the expression
dispatchers from the front
line what is supposed to be peacefully
gathered namely facts about some State
of Affair out there looked at
dispassionately by people who are
entirely
disposable once they have made the
discovery those fact have become the
front line of conflicts where discover
their feet deep in the mud of the
trenches are fully
visible fully accountable and without
any Escape Route to the
rear ler in French I couldn't find
translation now risk being at War about
what is in the
world as to the discoverers they are
very much in The
Fray and would share the responsibility
if the public were to be
defeated so what in previous work I had
registered as a shift from matters of
fact to matters of concern as taken on
an added intensity stency and urgency
and that's at the point that the
question of agency meet those of
politics well since we are talking about
front line I don't want to hide but I
wish to help the Michael man of this
word I too wish to hear the warning if
you see something say
something unfortunately for you this
mean that as I planned earlier I have to
shift my analysis of agency from
simotics to
ontology and it's not without qualm that
I introduce this word here since I'm
well aware that ontology is one of those
scare word that frighten away many
colleagues except if you are from
computer science which means on
something different which is strange if
you think of it natural scientists are
the last one who should deem it an odd
to term since they have no corns
whatsoever in stating for their writings
fortunately what things are which is
exactly what the word ontology means the
study of what is and yet by bringing in
the word ontology and it would be the
same with the word metaphysics it's true
that philosophers introduce small
warning a trouble some sort of
disquette of restlessness about what
things are as if they were not so sure
that those things are what they are and
of course that's the effect I wish to
convey especially if we have to deal
with those sort of proliferating hybrids
that seem to be stating simultaneously
what is and how we should behave when we
meeting them like everything in the
anop to move things out a bit I will use
the word ontology in a sense slightly
different from the common usage not as
the science of being but in a sense
closer to what is not ethologically
correct still a neighor
deontology I will Define deontology as
the Diplomatic care with which we
collectively come to grips with what is
and what should be assembled in the
common
world deontology is the skill necessary
in my jargon to move toward the task of
composition very much a consequence of
what I called yesterday
accountable I'm afraid that the
operation I have to accomplish now is
fairly delicate and completely
speculative of course we have to render
ourself able to come to grips with what
is experienced in the
world and however we have been warned
both that it's very unlikely that we
will ever encounter this entity those
agent
under the form of object known by
subject the older settlement of matters
of fact if we cannot pick and choose
it's because entities are given in
experience through many other moods this
is why one type of description cannot
eliminate another time remember
Whitehead's interrogation of how to
avoid the distinction between two
experience of how red is being given the
real question
is when red is found in nature what else
is found there also namely we are asking
for an analysis of the accompaniments in
nature of the discovery of red in nature
this is from concept of nature his
solution well known now for the
commentary by Isabel Sten is fairly
radical no perplexity concerning the
object of knowledge can be solved by
saying that there is a mind knowing
it in other word epistemology will lead
us
nowhere the question is not to have a
world and then a human mind which in the
anthropos would mean nothing but first a
world whose various trajectory are grasp
while freed from the added
complication whad says the model of
being known by
someone you might already have heard
this famous sentence from the concept of
nature the same book I just
cited my argument is that this dragging
in of the Mind as making addition of its
own to the thing posited for knowledge
by sense
awareness is merely a way of shering the
prime of natural
philosophy that problem is to discuss
the relation inter say which is a
crucial expression of things known
abstracted from the bare fact that they
are known and this is the famous
sentence natural philosophy should never
ask what is in the mind and what is in
nature now you might be surprised to see
this quote being celebrated by someone
like me who claims to be loyal to the
field of science
studies because this what this field has
accomplished on the face of it is
exactly the opposite of what is
requested here by
whad have we not Dragged In not only the
mind but also all trappings of scientist
at work instrument their laboratory
their Grant application their writing
documents paper and inscription of All
Sorts if there are people who have
caused the model of importing the mere
procedure of thought into the fact of
nature is it not those writer from
science studies and I said above the
situation has been confused to the point
where it's now impossible to discuss the
relation inter of things known
abstracted from the bare fact that they
are
known in that sense science study in
spite of his long-standing polymics
against epistemology seems to play in
the end exactly the same
role as if a Greek etimology of the
latter had caught up with the English
translation science student is a mere
replay of
epistemology and the mind is Dragged In
equipped with more paralia to be sure
but still the model is just as thorough
White's project however was not to push
the Mind aside in order to get some Prim
Primal access to word of nature but to
make sure that we don't confuse the
entities which are encountered in
experience with the additions the extra
work to be done in order to grasp them
as things
known white did realize that when we
encounter an entity as an object
we are actually encountered a hybrid mve
of at least two entirely different
layers one which is sense awareness and
whose trajectory is accessible for what
called the passage of
Nature and the other which is the
procedure of Mind necessary to ensure
the movement of another trajectory that
of discursive
knowledge it's by distinguish those two
but
trajectory that he is able to show that
what is often taken to be the material
world is not an autous Aboriginal stuff
encountered in
experience but the idealist product of
an amalgam between at least two types of
experience those two should be clarified
first in order for any natural
philosophy to fulfill its Duty namely I
quoted yesterday to analyze how these
various element of nature are
connected hence whiteed well-known quote
where materialism is revealed as a fully
idealistic rendering of
experience thus what is a mere procedure
of Mind in the translation of sense
awareness into discursive knowledge has
been transmuted the well transmuted is
important into a fundamental character
of nature in this way matter has emerg
as being the metaphysical substratum of
its property you remember the substance
attribute before and the course of
nature interpreted as the history of
matter half of the stuff of out of which
matter is conceived is made of a manner
for which we have access to some states
of
Affair and if we don't want to Sher the
prime of natural philosophy the question
becomes how to make sure that when we
encounter entities we don't immediately
lose track of them by treating them as
object which would mean if you have
followed the argument to direct our
attention not toward the world but
toward the
mind as William James would have said we
don't want more than what is experienced
but we don't want less
either object is the wrong qualification
for for things in the world as well as
for what it is for them to be known
objectively that's where science studies
in spite of what I said above could come
in
handy if white head's argument seem so
difficult to grasp is because it still
deal with the Mind an abstraction just
as unexamined as that of matter but as
soon as we replace the Mind by active
profession of scientists that work Works
in laboratory assembling the document
extracted from the instrument and
writing account validated by many so
scholarly
institutions it becomes much easier not
to confuse such a trajectory with that
of a passage of
nature the distinction between the
fundamental character of Nature and the
many procedure to translated into what
is known is just to capping in the
language of inquiry
this is in our jargon The Crossing rep
ref for those who are in the no this is
just what I emphasized yesterday a
careful rendering by garinger and his
colleagues of how an optical pulser had
been discovered allow them to detect
exactly the juncture at which the local
situation of the astronomer was
traversed by another historical route
that later become construed as a
Galilean object known by
astronomy when this juncture is
carefully registered it becomes possible
not to model the two model sorry the two
movement that of how entities move into
the world are that of how we gain access
to them through our Instrumentarium by
localizing the exact Locus where they
cross each
other and this has nothing to do with a
mind looking at the word of object
had we simply dragged the mind in we
would have missed this articulation
that's the key point but when we drag in
the whole set of circumstances and
material equipment this time it can no
longer be
missed in other words if we could
succeed in fully localizing in the word
the very activity of knowing we might be
able to simultaneously meet the forward
movement of entity and the counter
movement of objectivity without mixing
the two and without for that being
forced to stick to the mind or to this
AAS of Mind called social construction
we would be able to come closer to what
I have called in the former lecture the
wave from if we could do this then
science studies will render a service
that epistemology has never delivered
science study ofer the counter poison to
poison to epistemology if I can say
that why is it so extraordinary
difficult to localize knowledge making
why is it so hard to specify knowledge
as a mode of existence in the world and
not a mode of existence of the world
totally absent from the world that is
unaccountable I sometimes feel that I've
been doing nothing else in the last 40
years but pondering over this problem
respect for objective knowledge is
Possible only if it's fully
localized no matter how far it extends
and yet it seemed to flee as soon as we
consider
it so if I want to have a slightest
chance to make my point tonight and have
a try after so many tries I have to
block all the Escape Routes for which
objective knowledge flies away as soon
as it's
produced it's the only manner to help
not only whiteed speculative philosophy
to be better understood it does not need
me but also mik man and his Spear and
those might need my help on their front
line since this is such a difficult
Point let me make up a simple almost
trivial example to get an idea of the
movement I should try to
counteract the other day I was on a
panel with a physicist George Smo a
Nobel Prize winner one of a discover I'm
sure you know of cosmic microwave
background
radiation and if I tell you the name of
the panel the cosmology iCal function of
art you will deduce no question that it
was in
Paris where else we search a title to
summarize the advance of his science
smooth smooth showed to be audience of
mostly literary people a film that took
us from the Earth all the way to the big
bang and back through carefully mounted
mixtures of data about galaxies gathered
in his lab and digital special effect
straight out of Hollywood the
possibility of moving backward all the
way to
380,000 years after the big bang was of
course
stunning and yet I could not help being
at at e at ease because what was shown
as a filmshot by some character whose
setic ectoplasm has been delegated
almost 13 billions years away into a
universe totally different from what it
is now was not only a fiction kep play
had used it okay but also a complete
misrepresentation of the work done by
smooth himself and his colleague to
assemble those very same data or rather
sub naturally it was not a betrayal for
smooth himself since as a physicist
specialist of the field while we the old
pool goed at the film he was mentally
replacing every smooth picture by the
thousand of hayatus that had been
necessary to overcome in order to mount
such a
fiction for us however it was impossible
not to be taken in while we were
watching the Hollywood equivalent of a
scientific world
view to be sure it was not a world of
Galilean object the film was clearly
advertised as an artist rendition but
still it was a narrative that
exemplified in my view all the bad
habits of
epistemology knowledge had been spirited
out the universe that it deployed in
front of us in a way that made it
totally impossible for the audience to
replace the competence granted to any of
the entities flying on the screen with
the list of their performances we had no
way to break the narrative by mental
reservation at smooth did in a word the
film made physics
unaccountable not exactly a fraud of
course since many real suata had been
stitched together but still as far as
possible from how such of science has
been
produced the result was that we were
asked to witness a highly simplified
example of a model denounced by
Whitehead the passage of nature was
replaced by bits and pieces of data
surreptitiously smoothed out by
narrative but make things just as
unaccountable if taken as an artistic
piece it was not art or as if considered
as a science report it was not science
and yet it appear to be a realistic
version of what the world in itself is
supposed to look like just an example of
a spirous realism that is associated
with the notion of the material world I
couldn't find the film but I've been
interested for many years in this film
but I'm sure you know the powers of 10
everyone at school has seen it and you
remember this is the story of built by
the great uh designer and film maker IMS
where you move by every time power of 10
move moving up all the way to the
galaxies and then you go back to Chicago
the loan and then you go down again
every time I'm sure you remember the
thing every time a power of
10 and this is the general film but is
as if you could really go from The Big
Bang basically to the particles going to
every single Direction and of course
this is completely
impossible this is exactly the smooth
version I mentioned before so this
morning I'm trying to make sorry for the
Primitive characters of this little
Montage what would be a realistic
representation of the powers of 10 if we
were taking seriously the high by which
science is produced so if you had to get
there you would have to be the satellite
view would have to be in the office of a
satellite somewhere in Chicago it would
be quite funny to do it just in Chicago
without moving out and of course of
course if you have a Galaxy you have to
be somewhere else you have to be in a
place a very specific place where you
can actually watch galaxies I'm not sure
if it's and if you are receiv a hand and
begin to see the hand as a surgeon you
have to be somewhere where the surgeon
work and if you want to get inside the
microscopy you have to be somewhere
where the microscopy is visible and you
see the point I want to make that is if
we have to do a film again we would have
to be we would be unable to smooth or to
order by power of 10 what we would mean
was actually moving with a taxi inside
Chicago going from one institution of
science to another institution of
Science and drawing something entirely
different from what is shown in the
power of 10 and if you have money to
give me to do the film I promise I will
do and I will uh put your name at the
beginning of this
film what is interesting is that two
entirely different worldview coming from
that there is no connection between the
one which you said and you have to take
word view and scientific word views
seriously one of them is actually
smoothing the high the whole the Hiatus
while the other is on the contrary
showing the Hiatus and there's as much
information in both of
course this allows me to point out that
in addition to the localization of
scientific practice in space and in
institution a necessary task to which
the H of science studies has dedicated
itself it's important to add its
localization in time and that's what I
want to show Now by this I don't only
mean the well documented inversion that
has been often noticed when facts in the
making become become old made fact the
slow Erasure of a scientist at Works
makes a lot of sense of course once the
fact is established there is no more
reason to parade the Discover than for
the authors of a novel to signal at each
pce page that he or she is the author of
the novel except of course for special
effect rather I'm interested in what it
means for the procedure of science to
take place after the phenomena the
encounter and then to retrofit the
encounter as if science had taken place
before the phenomena but in an invisible
and unknown
fashion so I want to distinguish the two
movements one that makes possible an
access to what is far away the other
that reorganize the move movement as if
it was coming from a far away to now
time inversion which is very interesting
what happens when we develop that is
when we narrate the unfolding of some
knowledge not as it has been discovered
that is from its consequence back or
more exactly its performances but but
but by starting from its causes in other
word what is achieved when we tell
causes and consequences St
story there is something deeply
troubling in making all phenomena the
belated consequence of the laws of
nature as soon as you claim that the
agencies encountered in experience obey
a law immediately the law takes over the
role of a substance of a competence
while what happens that is the set of
properties of performances are
retrograded to the status of mere
phenomena mere appearances that's
theology what could IDE be dispensed
with once we have grasped the law that
governs them through the veil of
appearance you could see the hard
substantial core of what makes them what
they
are what is troubling is that this has
nothing to do with the way
laws now in the legal sense accomplish
their own peculiar movement forward and
nothing either with the meaning of law
in politics and naturally nothing either
with the way they are generated and
extracted in scientific practice
strangly enough the laws of nature seem
to govern phenomena without their
sovereignty having the legal political
and scientific Foundation they
deserve apparently that was not a prime
During the period of
modernism but it has become crucial
issue now that we are said to live in
the geohistorical epoch of the
anthropos we absolutely want to know
what is the Sovereign we we are to obey
and what are its legal scientific and
political
credential that's what prime Michael man
and many others are struggling with
that's what they cry for their Frontline
under which laws are we fighting for
what Sovereign are we ask to sacrifice
our career and maybe our
life of course one could say that
because of a constraint of language any
report any account has to T to State
first the causes and then the
consequences but it's perfectly normal
to place the actor owed with the role of
a cause before those playing the role of
consequences even though everyone knows
perfectly well that every time
consequences have been grasped long
before their closes in one narrative the
earth and the skies is obviously there
long before the seed of truth that are
naturally in our souls as decart says
and it's just fairly convenient to tell
the story as if from the first principle
the earth and the sky could be simply
DED this is the beginning of the second
part of the discourse of meod where
decart in his beautiful style says that
he has deduced from first principle that
there was an earth and a sky or maybe
her Heaven
actually everyone knows that smooth as
well just as well as
decart and yet what is perfectly known
is also just as perfectly well
forgotten this is why I think that it
would be too reassuring to say that
there is nothing more in this appeal to
the laws of nature or in the Lal Montage
of the powers of 10 in this inversion of
antant and consequent there is nothing
innocent in such an apparently innocuous
inversion because for such an inversion
something crucial has been lost and
something equally crucial has been added
what has been added is that the
phenomenon is now running from its cause
to its consequences along a pavement
that is made of all the instrument
inscription formalism that had to be
generated one after the other to gain
access to it but in the reverse
order the result is that just as we
smooth or deard special effect scenario
all the
Hiatus that had to be cleared one after
the other for the scientists to go from
their Observatory to the invisible far
away State of Affair and now smoed over
and transformed into a perfectly regular
and unpro trajectory gliding from the
cause and its consequence High to have
disappeared but the stuff out out of
which they are made is still there
playing now the role of a Tac so to
speak where phenomena can now land as so
many
mechanical
planes and the pr that the same cond for
which access to the farway had been
gained is also used as the con employe
to bring them
back except that now on their return
Journey they are behaving as known
entity this is what why they are called
Galilean object to remain in existence
as durable entity they no longer have to
make any
efforts the language of of the inquiries
here
rep but simply to confide their
durability to the ways for which they
have been accessed with except that now
all the obstacles are now impossible to
notice since all traces of knowledge in
the making have been erased the
procedure of the mind to use whad
expression has become the very stuff in
which what is known also
resign everything happen as if from now
on entities of the world once they are
known we made in
knowledge knowledge in the word becomes
knowledge of a word a word of which
science capital S has become the
absentee
landlord if I now turn to what has been
lost you might recognize why there is
nothing innocent in those scientific
World
shows what has been lost is the
possibility to encounter in experience
entities of the world in any other mode
than the one of objective
knowledge of course this itself would
not be a problem if by objective
knowledge we mean the forward
movement
oops if
sorry if we mean
the but it's a big Prime if by objective
knowledge is also meant the return Jour
on the
top where knowledge has become the
contrete where what is to know something
has entirely
vanished now we are facing a spous
reality a phantom where it's impossible
to distinguish in the entities we
encounter how things stand in the world
and what we have to do to access them
objectively once they are entirely made
in knowledge how to know them has become
impossible to
retrieve strangely enough just at the
moment when everything seem to be made
off or in knowledge it's knowledge that
has been withdrawn from the world
objective
knowledge especially problematic is the
role given to
scientists when things come back on
their return Journey the only way to
follow them is to become yourself a
Galilean object that is a Galilean
subject you now have to believe that
your cognitive ability your own body the
genes out of which are made all of those
entity are themselves made of the same
stuff as objective knowledge The Phantom
of objectivity by contamination leaves
in its wake a phantom of
subjectivity and soon soon enough emerge
the double ghost Mind Body the only
inhabitant of the deserted World it
smells like materialism except that it's
nothing but the indefinite extension of
an idealistic rendering of matter
onology has been so stabilized that
there is no longer any room for any
other
encounter if you compare knowledge
making to the chlorophile function
invented by plants to extract from the
Sun a power of development that did not
exist before them everything happens as
if plants were imagining that the Sun
the Earth the universe all the way to
the Big Bang were made exclusively in
chlorop
a comfortable green dream to be sure but
one that does not allow plants to
encounter what is in the real world or
to take another metaphor it's like
imagining that clocks under the pretext
that their regular circular movement
allows them to provide humans with an
instrument to detect the passage of
nature we're now fantasying that all the
movement of the world were made in the
same tick tick tick tick as the one they
go through a nice dream for a clock
maker but not one that would made it
possible to meet any entity of the real
world beginning with
plants one of course could object that
it doesn't matter much Galileo himself
was not a Galilean object as to the cart
he never believed for a minute that his
body was a machine witness his private
letter and his great attention to diet
and chicken broth especially was very
much chicken B practicing scientists are
doing something entirely different from
what they say the word is like when they
project films in their world showrooms
they all know that those shows are for
the public and to render things simpler
for meere pedagogical reason and no one
will be silly enough to confuse the tick
of a clock with the passage of nature
right nobody did well once again what
everyone knows very well is also what
everyone forget just as quickly are not
scientists often victims of their own
scientific
worldview but I agree it makes not that
much of a difference when we have to
deal with Optical pulses or Big
Bangs the situation is entirely
different however when what is
encountered are entities that insist on
being encountered on other
grounds this is especially the case when
they have values
urgency importance intense
all features that are not to be confused
with that of being accessed through
rectified objective knowledge it's also
the case when we pertain to what
concerns the habitat inside which we all
reside in those cases it might be
terribly important maybe criminal to
miss the many other ways in which they
request to be
encountered and this might be well the
case when Michael man appeals to the
Inconvenient Truth of the anop TRC
origin of climate change but also if you
remember the example with which I ended
my lecture yesterday of what it is to
have a gene for unton
Korea there the last thing you want
would be to confuse how objective
knowledge is extracted from the gene
performances with how they
insist on acting upon us it's this
insistence that the stabilized ontology
of Galilean object does not
register but it is exactly what I've
called deontology should learn to
counteract an ontological Quest or
diplomatic encounter should be placed
just there to make sure that the return
Jour of Galilean object may be
interrupted by Hiatus whenever
necessary the world is no more made of
in knowledge but it is made in chlorop
it's being objectively knowable and it
has life at least on Earth but that's
not a reason to confuse the two
statement let me now bring those two
lectures to a
close from the time I was granted the
honor of giving the Tanner lectures and
I thank the committee for having chosen
me and the president
especially I've been worried by I've
been worried by the umbrella term I have
to confess on human
values I suspect that the usual way in
which this appeal to human value is
construed is that there exist an
objective world of material stuff to
which it would be really good of
Scholars in the humanity to be so kind
as to add some supplement of
Soul value in suchar of you is not a
property of a valueless word but only of
humans and human is of course also much
of a
part it is not an entity whose shape has
been determined once and for
all especially when anthropology shifts
so much at the time of the
anthropocene to the point of having to
deal with human qua
geology how to stabilize the shape of
those human with the long Trails of CO2
they leave in their
wake the gene that so many Laboratories
running on biopan are multiplying every
day those digital prosthesis that seem
to be a more and more intimate part of
them those calculating device to which
they are so hooked up that they end up
behaving for good as omo economicus a
figure just as bizarre as that of homo
geologic clearly the idea of a
stabilized human having to add hopefully
some value to a deserted world cannot be
the final
story rather it correspond to an
extraordinary local provincial
ethnocentric and highly artificial
Narrative of what it is to be in and
with the world it is the freeze frame of
an Epoch that has never been
exent this is why I propose to shift our
Focus toward an entirely different
phenomenon that of the many ways for
Which shapes are exchanged
I call it a metamorphic Zone not only
because of a nice geological connotation
very much in the spirit of our
geohistorical time but mainly because
it's where the various morphism if I can
say so gain their
suffixes fuzzy morphism this is our
befriended Pulsa gives a shape to a
phenomenon just as much as the
biomorphism of a gene responsible for
the terrible Huntington career or for
that that matter the ideom morphism of
White's concept they are all agents
agencies characters that do things and
those content can be counted only in so
far as the set of situation and trials
out of which they slowly emerge maybe
recounted it would make absolutely no
sense to say that some are inanimate
While others are
animated to play the role of the
inanimate cause of some other
consequences require just as much
animation as that of playing a human
owed with intention and
will remember the process of
countercurrent in the kidney and that of
A procession in the example yesterday to
write without
animation without granting intention to
our agent to ask them to behave as if
they had no value indeed to write as if
you had no style and are not writing at
all is a style all the same and so is
the custom of telling a cause and
consequence story as if the caes had
really been there before the
consequences it's another
Montage one that produce interesting
effect but a montage all the
same however as long as we remain in
narrative in text in semiotics the
argument may be posible but it has no
teeth it Remains What folks in the
humanity say about the natural
world what I try tonight is to move one
step further and to see whether it could
be used to draw a diplomatic Zone where
another deontology should
apply a deontology whose rule is for
natural philosophy everything perceived
is in nature we may not pick and
choose as we saw the main difficulties
to build the new scene so that we
benefit from objective knowledge without
letting the participant believe that
what is being objectively known is
itself made of the same stuff as what
the entities to be
known for that it's imperative to
localize the very activity of knowledge
making forly attributed to ghostly mind
in space yes in in institution and also
in time no matter how far it extend all
the way to the Big Bang at this point
reductionism enter the scene in two
opposite version as I said yesterday a
positive one no agency without its
performances and a negative one a
substance deprived of its real
properties if we manage to keep the
second out of
room that is out of a diplomatic
encounter
then many of the modes of insisting
about what it is in the world may be
registered then those who are in the
room are no longer human adding value to
a valueless
world but rather diplomatic shape
changer who are able to register the
values that are in the world the values
are in the world they no longer have to
imagine a ghostly world inside which
they are then
present except they themselves are
spirited out of it they can be of this
Earth which is after all what we are all
aiming at
no then it might be slightly less
surprising for scientist and citizen
like to have to deal with entity that
insist with intensity and
urgency and not just because human are
prone to project Their Fear or their
interest upon an indifferent
world the adjective inconvenient in the
call to heed Inconvenient Truth might be
a true property of the world as well or
at least that's the possibility that
I've have opened the scene might be more
friendly for Michael man and his
comrades on the front
line to be a subject encountering an
object is no longer a viable position at
least it is no longer the only one that
could allows us to decide where in those
walls We Stand thank you very
much hello thank you very much Miss I
have a comment and a
question uh your idea of the metamorphic
Zone your idea of the metamorphic Zone
Zone reminded me of the category of
firstness in Charles P's Philosophy was
very dear to me and then a question I
have going back to
yesterday when you talked about the
mutual enemy of the humanities and the
Sciences you were very careful not to
use the word business or business school
but to focus on specifically this
quality of evaluation so I was curious
to ask how does business fit into the
project of uh re search in the human
Humanities and Sciences or it does it
for
you Pur p is of course very important um
if you can if if I could manage to
understand him which is always Prim with
Pur but of course when I use semiotics I
could also do a lot of things with Pur
stic I use more the Continental gassian
one but you're right uh the connection
is very strong especially as the sort of
ontological Pur access to a world
science being and science is a
synonym um why did I talk about business
uh well I could have talked about
capitalism and neoliberalism Etc but
this was not the object of a study I
gave a talk on capitalism a few weeks
back uh and that would have been the
important to bring in I think the notion
of evaluation in universities and more
generally in the domain of scholarship
is actually yes it's pushed by business
businesses but it's also a self-imposed
torture so it has a
strange characteristic of sadow
masochism as well and it's also part of
a vast domain which is not connected
directly to business of self- auditing
the audit society as Marin ston says uh
and the self auditing for everything
which is now this possibility of
covering ourselves with self auditing uh
without the help of the NSA I mean just
we we do it perfectly well ourselves so
it's a it's a much vaster Trend which
which probably the business are of
course profiting from it but I think we
we could not imagine how much uh people
are ready to play the role of the homo
economic it's vastly expanded by
ourselves so to speak self-imposed
injury I'd
say I'm I'm over I have one over here hi
I thank you again um I wanted to ask a
question about diplomacy and how one
would articulate the difference between
diplomacy and say bad faith uh so that
when smooch shows you his film you say
he knows perfectly well but which seems
like the characteristic formulation of
bad faith uh how do you want to avoid
say stepping on your diplomatic efforts
by giving off an air of bad
faith why do you say it's bad faith I
mean what's perfectly in good faith he
thought it was a great film it was a
great film in this way and he was
perfectly uh happy to show it as a
pedagogical view of what he had
discovered why why do you put bad faith
here I'm not sure I understand
um the The Diplomatic move yeah seems to
at times bracket off what one really
knows about the situation and an effort
to appeal in some way no I think
diplomatic in the in the sense which is
again is one of his concept which tricky
because it comes from geopolitics and
it's has been restated byab S as a as a
concept philosophical concept so to
speak I take it as meaning Diplomat meet
when there is
no
referee which is commonly established my
model is the beautiful book on the
middle ground in the negotiation between
the Indians and the beginning of the
colonial power in Canada and and here
actually New Haven basically um and the
middle ground is precisely that when
there's no state yet and people are
don't know what the cosmology of each
other and they begin to feel that they
might have some occasion to agree but at
the smallest dispute they would go free
way and I'm not myself a great Diplomat
especially not with the scientist I have
to say I'm I mean I had lots of
difficulty with that argument but on
this in this specific case I was more
successful to say because I reminded it
but he was making all this
transformation while he was seeing the
film of course the sort of
transformation I tried to imitate very
naively with my little montage and we
didn't see it so I asked him why and of
course it would have been ridiculous
because it meant we would have had to
learn much more physics than was
necessary there but that's the that's
what I I mean by diplomacy I mean a
place where you you try you try not to
stabilize the cosmology but you are
meeting because of the urgency of a
situation so it's not because it's not
an academic discussion it's it's an you
are urgently trying to save your
skin with
others without the power of a state and
without Referee on top of you
and then you have to find a solution
which is very provisional and highly
tentative I I'm just coming back from
Montreal where we did that for two days
with the lawyer with law with law it was
very interesting so I I I now know that
it can work but it it's very very
difficult because of course it's not the
situation where we were used to in which
we were used to uh behave before because
the cosmology was basically there it was
nature culture so the nature was at
least the part where we could agree and
then there was cultural and different
but at the time of the anthropos is the
nature itself which is also up for gra
so diplomacy is what happen when you
have simultaneously multi naturalism and
multiculturalism to deal with basically
so you need another encounter but and of
course bad faith is a is a perfectly
possible uh thing I mean you you you you
have to have
think of Mr Putin if you want okay of
bad faith
probably if I understood your question I
might have
not thank you very much for your uh
generative
remarks uh I had a question from
yesterday and so it uh frames itself
today uh in terms of your remarks and
it's about the the role of Senses I
wanted to ask you to say a bit more
about that and the question comes to me
this way today
uh I want to visit those places that are
generative of knowledge that's how I
took some of your remarks to to recall
those places where knowledge is
generated and I'm reminded of the
Anthropologist Keith basso who did a
lovely little book wisdom sits in places
where he recalled early in his
anthropological career
uh walking the fence line with an Apache
colleague they were repairing the fence
and he uh heard his
colleague uh uh singing and so he asked
him what are you
singing and he said the Apache friend
said I'm saying place
names and basso asked him why and he
said it's it's enjoyable for me it's uh
it uh it's Pleasant and so it set off an
invest a research track for basso and he
connected that then eventually with uh
knowledge Gathering and the transmission
of
Ethics so the the connection I wanted to
make and the question I wanted to ask is
for uh these people these indigenous
people in the southwest singing or a
mode of sensing was a way of
recalling what I I hear are you talking
about those places in which knowledge is
generated and so I wanted to inquire of
you what rule do the senses play could
you say a bit more about that in this uh
in this project that you're laying out
for us yeah this is a complicated
question because um well actually I was
in Montreal with the other guys wearing
this popo of the middle ground was
Eduardo Kon who has written a book very
close to the one you mentioned uh called
how Forest
think uh which is very much in that same
uh spirit of using actually sematic of
Pur interestingly enough so the
difficulty we have several Point first
knowledge I use knowledge but in in the
inquiry I'm pursuing knowledge should be
coded with the
mode in this it's model in the reference
mode and there are of course lots of
other knowledge as you mentioned so U
knowledge is not a category that can be
entirely absorbed by this very highly
specific uh mode in which we produce
access to the Far Away by building the
instruments I mentioned in the in this
uh in those lectures there are lots of
other but the operation I think
necessary to which also coming from Tim
ingold whom I cited yesterday also one
of his Anthropologist very interested in
other mode of knowledge
the difficulty is to
extract to
let the phenomena free I can that those
of rep in my
inquiry uh free from free from being
known so to speak this is the operation
and in my uh reading of the literature
it's really only whad who managed to do
that so of course it's very important
the anthropology has been extraordinary
important in showing many other ways of
getting the sense of the world through
completely different
pattern but the difficulty uh and the
urgency in which we now are in this
situation I'm trying to U create the
Diplomatic encounter is that we need the
Sciences we need the objectivity of the
sciences and we need the possibility for
phenomena to be sense to use your
expression uh to or more exactly we have
to make ourselves sensitive two
phenomena which have other
characteristics for instance one of them
to be urgent or inconvenient or uh
stress stressing all property which have
property of the word and of course in
that case we reconnect in very
interesting ways with uh the sort of
situation that you describe in uh this
book that is situation where the see the
whole the whole situation is that it's
not the human who are knowing the word
is that the word comes to them and
transform them and that's this movement
of which there are many many other
example in the anthropological
literature and that we begin to rehear
differently now that we are facing the
ecological
mutation so I'm not sure I followed your
exactly your
question but I Tred to turn in the
direction it was indicating but is the
many other way in which we have to be
able to prepare ourself to get the
entities with their values in themselves
and not only our imposition to them and
it's not an opposition between brain
knowledge and I mean mind intellectual
knowledge and the
senses because the guys I showed
yesterday you heard the tape were doing
the astronomy they are full with their
senses there in the situation just as
much as the guy you cited but it just a
very different situation so I don't
think a difference should be put in
senses properly U even probably Tim
inard will disagree with me but it's
more of a question of being able to
register other modes of
insisting and the only way is to make
knowledge what we call knowledge
referential knowledge completely visible
in the
situation and not confuse that with the
the way the the situation come to us
another way to say that it's a
rephrasing of lots of things that
William James already
said
hello in my humble understanding of
Hindu
philosophy the uh basic understanding of
the material world is that it came into
existence inherently out of a duality so
out of the desire
for the uh of the desire of the universe
to to observe itself so there's a kind
of and that in implicit in that is a
kind of beginning of of Illusion or of
confusion my question is about that
initial stuff from which matter comes
into being in this lecture you used an
analogy of the of the uh of the plant
fixing sunlight of the chlorophyll in
another um metaphor of of yours you
talked about magma uh cooling into
tectonic plates one with which might be
society and one which might be nature
I'm I'm trying to understand what that
stuff is which is Cooling and I'm having
trouble uh getting there I'm I'm
wondering how you would how you would
answer are we and it it begins to feel
perhaps ethereal if we're talking about
sunlight so I'm I'm just wondering how
how would you answer um to to a The
Humble question of what is this what is
this stuff which is cooling or which is
fixing well if you call that a h
question I doubt what is a serious
Advanced question because that question
is about what the stuff out of the world
is made of okay
um I I out of ADV vast question I
extracted the little one which is by the
way whad was very influenced by Indian
and Chinese philosophy of course uh so
was the whole period around turn of a
century um I just extracted one little
string in this thing which is not to
confuse what we call matter with the
idealist idealism of matter so the
matterial what we which is what of
course why the Discover is that what we
call matter in our tradition is very
different of course for Indian tradition
is since the 17th century doesn't work
for the 16th century it's a highly
localized invention basically some
create someone between Galileo Lo deart
and it's a very very local with um um
wer diagnosed as being the bifurcation
of nature into primary and secondary
equality from then on it has become
difficult for
philosophy and Strang Enough by uh
consequence for lots of other discipline
in science as well as in the art to
extract themselves from the idealism of
matter and that's the only thing I try
to do so I have no answer to your
question what is the stuff but but uh my
warning is don't try we we should not be
we should we should be able not to
confuse it with
uh the fact that they are known that's
why I like this metaphor of the
chlorophile to believe that the word is
made in knowledge because you know it
and you know it there's no question
about that and you know it objectively
is like
chlorophile confusing because of its
amazing success to extract from the Sun
this amazing possibility that the sun
didn't know it
had ah well everything is green no no no
everything is not green but chlorophile
is here on the earth you see that's a
Str metaphor I so okay so what's what is
the human analogy to
chlorophyll sorry what is the like what
part of me is analogous to chlorophyll
then if there's this like light stuff
out there that I'm CR that I'm fixing
into knowledge well there are
uh there are lots of things in you that
you don't want that the analog is from
the whole modes of existence that you
receive that make you what you are only
one of them is in
knowledge knowledge ref there are lots
of
others and if we begin the Diplomatic
encounter now which is the aim of the
inquiry we would begin to say on what
condition it is very important that I
understand the other stuff you want to
build in the common world and is this
acceptable to me that is can I live with
it or not can I survive in the common
word that we begin to do as a middle
ground in the Middle
Ground you see what I mean is that but
you're but I thought we were excited to
locate things so like can we not try to
locate it like what that what what is
doing the fixing yeah so how how would
you Lo at that maybe I'm I think I may
not be up to the logic that you're using
I'm not sure understand the second part
of the question what what I've heard you
say or ask is uh if we engaged in the
discussion diplomatic Encounter of
deciding upon the question of what the
stuff of which the world is made of yeah
we will have
[Music]
to put on the table our
cosmologies yeah and the cosmologies
will not be organized as they used to be
according to the Divide well cosmology
is from culture and Indian culture
Chinese culture American culture French
culture are
different but there is one thing which
is out of discussion its nature because
we share it it's the same in India as
here right this is the traditional way
of organizing the diplomacy it's not
very diplomatic because what remains to
be disputed is only
subjective or
cultural or
symbolic okay so what I'm trying to work
out is that in the situation of urgency
which is described by this word of the
anthropocene the middle ground is also
about
nature especially in the discussion
around
climate because after all the CL clate
signs are simultaneously the least
disputed fact and the most
disputed so even that is not
stabilized and that's why I use this
little sentence by mik man which seems
to be so
interesting but maybe tomorrow we can I
can understand better your question to
satisfy you better I feel that I've not
satisfied
you I I think it may be on
me
thanks uh okay so my question is about I
think uh this concept of existence and I
guess the inverse of um loss and um
you've talked about making visible the
plurality of modes of existence and I'm
curious how we then address something
like uh as simple as like a history
being lost when we dig up a Shard of
pottery and we don't actually know what
it's from or um who used it
and it seems like um there's this
magical quality of having multiple modes
where we can I think a word you use is
like give us spaciousness um in the
world of knowledge and and kind of give
space for fictitious characters to exist
um and so I'm curious what happens when
things fall out of those
networks
um and and are lost through just passage
of time and and and kind of other forces
that cause stories to cease to exist in
some
sense I have difficulty seeing where it
connects with what I said what it's a
story about it's a question about what
is lost in history
yeah but I I talk about Geo
story so maybe if this is a misunder I I
I I borrow the expression from De
shabati we actually use Geo history
so is is's a writer who did this very
important paper on the what does it
change in the definition of the act of
the actor of the history if we are now
talking about G history is this what the
question turn around maybe I'm there was
a poy in your question and I don't know
where the butry comes from but oh
um no I think that that makes well I
don't know what are you getting at with
if we are if we are in G the argument is
simple is that if if we are in GE story
it's like the image I showed of the
plane of the the Greenland is that uh
you can no longer have the stage and the
backstage because the backstage has
historicity just as much as a stage so
basically and it's a thing I I did a
play exactly to register this this
differences and the play actually but
the stage is active much more than the
actors on the play because that's that's
what is Capt in this question of the
anthropocene we have humans which have
been used for the during the Holocene
for 10,000 years to be in a relatively
stable uh sort of
stage U and now the backstage is moving
very very fast and seem to be highly
reactive to what the humans do so the
the notion of indifferent nature the
notion of being out of it the notion of
looking at it as a landscape the idea of
being disposable Observer under
contaminated by what happened all of
that is going is gone and that's what I
capture with the notion of
geostory and look I mean the numbers of
terms which are moving from history to
geostory is amazing people think like
catastrophe tipping points boundary
limits uh uh uh even the Str theological
term of Apocalypse they're all moving
back and forth from the stage to the
backstage that's that's the only part of
history that I mentioned in my
but again I might have misunderstood
your question I try maybe better
tomorrow you spoke yesterday I think
about academics tendency and and maybe
need to say things in ways that are
difficult or or slow or
complicated and you spoke today about
the need to say something if you see
something within a public forum are
those not pulling in in opposite
directions
I I understood the second one but what's
the first one so so yesterday you spoke
about academic Scholars tendency to say
things in ways that are slow or
complicated or difficult ah yes you have
to say Inconvenient Truth
slowly yeah that's a very nice Point uh
you well that's I think you put a very
important point which
is it would be terrible and it has
happened actually this is exactly why
why I'll go
was so criticized is that he went much
too fast in being in in put in being in
the position of being
right and saying well if I'm right then
policy will
follow the whole the whole ecological
thought constantly fail in that respect
we say we have a science then the policy
follow well we have a science policy
does not follow that's why diplomacy
comes in it has nothing to do when you
talk about truths Inconvenient Truth
which means the modification of the life
of 7 billion people don't expect policy
to follow a completely different scene
is open and that's why scientists are
very uncertain so it would be of course
the the the the the idea would be well
urgency is so strong let's go very fast
doesn't matter if it not exact that
would be a catastrophe on the contrary
you have to slow down precisely because
it's urgent that's again what the middle
ground is four you
negotiate on very very harsh condition
because the situation is urgent and
that's why you take time because you
know that every single hesitation on
that you the situation might degenerate
so I thank you very much for having
point for having pointed out what is not
a contradiction but I think it's a very
very important features it's not because
it's urgent that people are in
interested in all this question of
ecology should simplify you know this is
the old militant thing you have to make
them fear the most and the most they
fear the more they would move no no no
no the more we would be frightened the
less we will do look
Australia Australia is
amazing we are in a Terri the situation
has never been worse and what do we do
just get rid of all clate most climate
research so the terrified people will
not move it's very important for the
middle ground you have to have highly
terrified people who take a lot of
time
thanks so it seems to me uh that there
we're talking about two well we could
say we're talking about two movements uh
that scientists and people in the
Humanities ought to uh
make clearly there in the example say
yesterday of of observing the Pulsar
they're observing something outside of
themselves and so this ontology seems to
be uh trying to show that in fact they
are in commun community as it were with
these things that they're not so
different that they're not that those
things are not so far outside of of of
the science say but then there's a
second move which it's one thing to
identify but it's another to behave
ethically and it seems that that these
are uh woven together very importantly
but that their the the motion is not
necessarily implied I wonder it takes a
push I wonder if you could speak to that
point yeah I think that's a nice way
but isn't that the case that when we the
Pulsar is one of course a sort of
traditional Galilean object which can be
for which the epistemology doesn't need
really to be modified but when you deal
with with uh matters of concern in which
you are yourself andert unced which is
basically everything happening on Earth
especially climate but not only climate
um it's possible and that's I think the
way I hear uh Michael mans but also
Clive Hamilton and many of
his kunen himself or Hansen many of his
proposition but it's
simultaneously a matter of of fact in
the traditional way and a requirement to
behave in a certain
way so the distinction the classical
distinction between Mo basically moral I
mean the the way to behave and the way
to know is precisely modified in this
things but the pr that is very difficult
to articulate as long as we confuse the
way the world is made of and the way it
is known this is why whad is so so so so
important because the passage of nature
which allows knowledge to be produced is
not to be confused with the way we
access objectively there's no question
about it has nothing to do with not
being objective there it's completely
objective and again the the climate is
so interesting for me because it's a
case I mean there's no fact of Natural
History so so well known
and yet it's also the one where the
dispute is biggest not because there is
controversy because there is a way to
behave in the world added to it and all
those scientists trained the classical
epistemology are a bit lost I mean they
don't know how to handle this strange
thing they say so sometimes they fall
back on science separated from
policy sometimes they say like a big
like Hansen I mean they become a
militant of the course and then the
other guy says look they are militant
and they never dare to say yes we are
militant of course we are a
lobby but now show
you show me what you are lobbying for
who is paying you and then we will have
a
nice
confrontation thank you this was not you
of course I was not addressing
you at the end of this lecture you spoke
about the human as an morph Diplomat or
a a shape changer I me I'm wondering if
you can fit that into a posthuman
thinkers who would rather throw out the
idea of the human um or even Fuko when
he says that the human has come into
existence and is now at its end it was
not po human but it was of course uh
very I was cited mentally uh the sort of
donah har I mean the idea of that better
definition of human is shape changing
it's also because I'm influenced by
discussion I had last week with Eduardo
K precisely about the forest thing is
that no matter how many agencies the
human
receive um and the idea that you can now
get in sort of relation inter say as a
as white says it's quite
important to be able to define the human
especially at the anthropos scene what
is the anthropos of the anthropos scene
it's still very very important question
and of course anthropos is a very very
bad concept because the anthropos is not
UNIF there's no anthropos able to carry
out the earth I mean it's ridiculous the
Amazon Indian are not responsible for it
and the American I mean you basically
are more responsible than me in France I
need only two Earth and you need
five so it the anthropos doesn't exist
that's why it's so important to re
nevertheless in spite of what we say
it's not posum it's re we redefine a
humanism where the humans is actually
also a geological force me I don't know
how to do it but that's a problem and
without naturalizing again the Human by
thinking
slowly thinking slowly is absolutely
necessary that's why I mean there's
absolutely no reason to unite try to
unite Humanities and the Natural
Sciences except because of the question
of osine the urgency has nothing to do
with
interdisciplinarity or it's nice to talk
with physics and so on this is no it's
question is
urgent and it's the urgency that push
Diplomat to take seriously the question
of diplomacy if not it remains
a sort of intellectual
idea well that actually leads really
well into my question which is going to
be about um the use of the term
anthropos and whether that is um you
know as you mentioned in the beginning
there are other ways we could think of
the the prefix to the scene and um
whether you know whether whether that is
reinscribing the same human non-human
subject object distinction and you know
should we should we be calling it I
think I see people using anine a lot
it's really caught on um is that
something we should uh as Scholars be
concerned about and um maybe consciously
thinking about not using no I I agree
entirely with you I think the the half
life of of of anop is already passed uh
actually I found a site which is very
nice which is called the Mis
anthropos which I find a marvelous sign
um no I I mean I agree but that's and
also it's not even sure that the
geologist I I begin to know most of
those actually uh who have to
decide they are Strater very serious
person and they might be they might
decide in 2016 not to name the anthrop
so for lots of reason it has C up
because it's a very convenient term to
talk about lots of things which in my
field we have been discussing for 40
years I mean human nonhumans in hybrid
postum I mean all of these things now
it's highly simplified by the May strip
but I agree with you it solve absolutely
no problem it doesn't Define the anopa
it could be a renaturalization which of
course that's what many of the people in
the strateg graphy have in mind it's the
geology added to the definition of
humans now when I'm I'm engaged in a big
project on on co2 and actually this is
not so clear that is lots of scientists
are now very interested in linking the
notion of uh doing a geopolitic so to
speak of of a of a
former of a former chemical element so
uh if the world will pass and it has to
be used with great
care um but the situation is will there
will be another name because this meu
strip is here to
stay and and that's a large part of what
I'm doing now is trying to find the the
word for that so I agree with you
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks